on August 28th 2023 the Chinese
government released a
[Music]
map the map did a surprisingly good job
at making a lot of other countries angry
several countries have rejected China's
new standard map it's a violation of the
law that's where um I put that map the
release of this map also was met with a
huge event and announcement with in
China this featured the state media
launching into a commentary on the
importance of maps
followed by a warning to the people that
maps that have errors can cause quot
great harm to
society so let's look at what's going on
with this map why countries around the
region are condemning it and why China
had to go to Such Great Lengths to tell
people that there's nothing wrong with
these maps and that in fact a map like
this is key to National Unity to do this
I'm going to need a high-res version of
this map luckily the Chinese government
has me
[Music]
covered I want to show you what this map
says and show you how China uses
cartography to assert and project power
in its region because as clean as this
map looks within it there's actually a
lot going on Border tug-of Wars fake
Islands a tenth dash on a line in the
ocean barbed wire wrapped clubs and
proxy wars it's the perfect example of
how Maps aren't just Maps they're tools
of National
[Music]
Power I don't like the feeling of being
spied on and like all of us I am spied
on on all of the time not just by
governments but by corporations by
people who want to make money off of my
information that brings me to this quick
pause in our video to talk about our
sponsor incog incog is a personal
information removal service I don't like
the feeling of being spied on I don't
think any of us do but we all are kind
of spied on some of us by governments
but almost all of us are spied on by
corporations who collect our information
put it on these data broker lists and
sell it on an open market to people who
want to make money off of us luckily in
many countries including the United
States we have laws and rights to remove
ourselves from these lists but most of
us don't know how to do it it's a
cumbersome bureaucratic process and that
brings me to the sponsor of today's
video incog which is a personal
information removal service I've been
using incog now for a few months and it
has changed my world what you do is you
sign up for incog and you give them
permission and then they go through the
process of requesting that you be taken
off that list and if anyone push pushes
back like one of the corporations like
makes it harder incog follows through
with the process to make sure that you
get off of all of these lists and then
they update you month after month so
that you can see the progress you can
see your privacy being reclaimed the
people who want this information aren't
just marketers who want to sell you like
new tennis shoes but it's like people
search sites which are becoming a thing
that use this data to like put you on
these people search sites so people can
find your information health insurance
companies will sometimes buy some of
this data so that they can use like your
web browsing history to like Jack up
your health insurance bill and perhaps
most annoyingly it's spam I mean my
phone was constantly exploding with like
random Robo calls I got all these
fishing scams all of the time like my
information was everywhere and it was
blowing up my phone in my inbox I mean
there's no end to the shenanigans that
corporations will do to make money off
of you and your information no longer
luckily incog exists and I am genuinely
grateful for that unrelated to the fact
that they're sponsoring today's video
which like I'm very grateful for that
too I'm just grateful that they exist
because I don't like my information just
being everywhere so if you want to get
in on incog at a discount there's a link
in my description it's incog Johny
Harris when you click the link it helps
support the channel and it gets you 60%
off their annual plan the reason I have
the annual plan is because even if you
get taken off these lists you'll
eventually make it back on and having
incog there to constantly monitor these
lists and keep getting me off of them is
of value to me so the Link's in the
description use the code Johnny Harris
thank in cogy for sponsoring our
journalism and now it's time to dive
into this mapping story about China and
it's very very interesting new map the
government of China wants their country
to look like this but in reality it
looks a lot more like this we're going
to move left to right from India to
Taiwan in the South China Sea oh by the
way the Chinese government requires its
mapmakers to use this algorithm that
intentionally scrambles the latitude and
longitude coordinates of their maps all
in the name of National Security this
makes it hard for people like me to work
with Chinese Maps but we were able to
hack through these maps and line them up
with our own mapping systems which is
how we're able to make this video okay
with that let's get started first we
have Kashmir a region that is already
heavily disputed between India and
Pakistan the map shows that all of this
section is a part of China and indeed
China controls it but India claims that
this actually belongs to them it's the
source of conflict both countries are
building stuff in this region roads
communication Towers airfields
everything to be ready in case a
full-blown conflict breaks out troops
from both sides face each other in a
standoff at this line the line of actual
control that's really what it's called
it Loosely marks the border between
these two massive countries a border
that was never really agreed upon
because remember where we are here we're
in the Himalayas the tallest mountains
on Earth drawing lines and controlling
territory here just doesn't work super
well but both sides want to exert
control even here in the high mountains
especially in these important trade
regions these are two nuclear countries
and so they've agreed to not use
Firearms up here no guns so instead when
conflict breaks out it looks more like a
medieval battle with barb wire wrapped
clubs and fence posts the most recent
Clash was just in 2020 right here near
ladak 20 Indian soldiers and four
Chinese soldiers were killed Indian and
Chinese soldiers fought on disputed land
using stones and bamboo poles and around
two dozen people died as you go down the
border between India and China there are
several more of these pockets of
disputed land in the Himalayas as we
head east we'll hit Nepal and I have to
mention that there was recently a leaked
government report out of Nepal that
asserts that China is encroaching into
Nepal's Sovereign territory building
stuff with no permission on Nepal's side
of the Border here in the HLA District
Nepal actually didn't want this report
to come out they have to walk a fine
line being sandwiched between these two
Behemoth countries and a big part of
that means staying on China's good side
a few years ago I was up here shooting
an episode of Vox borders and the locals
told me that the Chinese military didn't
respect the Border they kind of did
whatever they wanted which is why it
wasn't even allowed to get up to the
Border fence between these two countries
it's an eerie feeling being so close to
a country that is so serious about
projecting its power to its neighbors
anyway let's keep going east where we'll
hit another landlocked country in the
Himalayas
Bhutan the Border here continues to make
an effort to divide these countries in a
rugged Glacier filled expanse back in
2006 China quietly pressured Bhutan to
give them this big chunk of mountain
territory and Bhutan conceded they
didn't really have a choice and so while
they kind of keep it Hush Hush China is
reminding the world that they actually
control this part of Bhutan it's theirs
now China's using the same playbook in
different parts of Bhutan blurring this
northern border as they encroach South
in 20120 China claimed that they
actually own this part of Bhutan a
forested nature Sanctuary but strangely
this official map doesn't show that this
area is inside of China's borders maybe
it will next year the most strategically
important part of China's claim on
Bhutan is here this little strip of land
gives us a better idea of why China is
squeezing the border of this tiny
country if you zoom out you'll see where
we are right here at this vital choke
point between these two Rivals India and
China this thin Corridor where India
connects to its eastern states some call
this the chicken neck the map asserts
that China owns this part of Bhutan the
doam plateau which provides them a
perfect military vantage point over the
chicken neck India's critical Corridor
this would make India vulnerable in the
case of an active conflict oh and their
claim is not just on the map satellite
imagery analyzed by Reuters shows that
China is building roads and settlements
and structures on this Sovereign
territory of Bhutan enhancing their
strategic military position and
fortifying their claim on the map these
border Shenanigans in Bhutan are
considered a proxy for tension between
China and India Bhutan like Nepal is
just sandwiched in the middle satellite
images of the Chinese incursions in
Bhutan where China has built roads and
barracks on the Undisputed territory of
Bhutan okay let's keep moving
on next to Bhutan China's map shows that
all of this land are within its borders
they now call it South Tibet but all of
this territory belongs to India it's
full of Indian
citizens India's claim to this land
relies on this 890 km borderline that a
British representative Drew in 1913 in
partnership with a representative from
Tibet who agreed to the line but China
says this isn't legitimate they own
Tibet now and they never authorized this
line dividing Tibet from India so on
their map they assert that all of this
belongs to China and to take it a step
further they're actually renaming stuff
on their maps in this region from
mountain peaks to rivers and cities
showing us how China wants to claim and
standardize every corner of its country
exerting control and influence even in
these remote places now India is not
standing by and letting this happen to
counter this the Indian government is
spending a half a billion dollars to
build roads and develop hundreds of
villages with the goal of solidifying
their claim to this land as we head east
let me mention that during the pandemic
China has been building a fence along
this border with Myanmar mostly to keep
people and elicit Goods out of China
this border has always been porous
people who share culture and language
would cross back and forth in formally
trading but this fence has totally
changed that and people are angry I've
considered doing an entire video on this
border fence and how it's disturbing and
affecting life here if that's
interesting to you please let me know in
the comments so while this isn't a
disputed territory it is another example
of China's increased effort to tighten
its control on every corner of its
land okay now we've arrived to the ocean
the part of the map that gets a little
wild the government map actually makes
it look simple all of the water inside
of this dashed line is China's but the
reality actually looks like
this this is what's known as the n-h
line and it was effectively a handdrawn
boundary by the Chinese government in
the 1940s it's not a precise border it
wasn't agreed upon by the countries here
and nor is it legal at least according
to the permanent Court of arbitration in
the heg who calls the n- line Lawless
because it clearly cuts through the
waters that that international law says
belong to these neighboring countries
and that's how you get this jumble of
all these
lines but as superpowers do China
ignores all of this because they can and
they continue to operate as if this
entire ocean which by the way is repl
with fish and fossil fuels as well as
militarily strategic islands and
important trade routes all of it is
theirs this has created active conflicts
with neighboring countries because for
China these aren't just lines on a map
[Music]
map China has been pumping sand onto
tiny reefs to create islands where there
were none then they build a military
outpost on these newly created islands
in the last decade they've built dozens
of these outposts throughout the South
China Sea and you can see that these
militarized islands are right inside the
waters that the world has agreed belong
to these other
countries the Chinese Navy also steps in
patrolling these Waters and routinely
harassing fishermen from other countries
reminding them that China isn't subject
to the rules this is their water just
like their official map says United
States is accusing China of harassment a
Filipino fisherman was chased by Chinese
Coast Guard speedboats as he made a dash
for the shallow Waters of Scaro show
last
Friday a similar dispute is happening on
a group of islands a little north of
here where Japan China and Taiwan all
claim these islands that are surrounded
by oil and gas Fields China will often
Flex on Japan by sending Coast Guard
ships into the water and airspace around
these islands this is their neighborhood
they think these islands are theirs and
they're going to assert that claim on
the map as well as in real
life on China's map Taiwan is included
as a part of China even though Taiwan
has been independent for decades China
insists that this is theirs and if push
comes to shove they've made it very
clear that they're willing to claim it
back by force and to that end this new
map includes an addition to the n-h line
a 10th Dash a line that drifts
dangerously North to encircle the water
east of
Taiwan this isn't the first time that a
10th Dash has appeared on a Chinese
government map but it is a meaningful
moment for the government to just slip
in another Dash and it's created a big
debate about what this actually means
but one thing that almost all experts
agree on is that China's ability to just
switch up their ocean Claim by adding
another Dash communicates the original
message of using a handdrawn line as
your Maritime claim which is that China
feels historically entitled to this
region to this ocean and they will
behave how they choose in their own
neighborhood especially at a time when
its neighbors are partnering with its
geopolitical rival the United States to
surround and encircle China with a large
military buildup in the
region the last one I'll mention is a
tiny one that's kind of surprising it's
up here where the map claims this River
Island that should belong to Russia
there was a dispute about this but 20
years ago Russia and China agreed to
redraw the Border like this giving half
of this island back to Russia but in
this map they claim it once again and no
one is totally sure
why so this new map out of China is a
series of political statements which
arguably every map map is some of these
are worthy of debate some are wishful
thinking and some are downright
aggressive but one thing is clear China
is now rich and powerful and motivated
to exert its geopolitical Vision in the
world it's a reminder that maps have
always been a tool for great powers to
express their aspirations and this map
in this modern day is no
different
[Music]